[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Welcome to the very first
update episode of Polycast.
In these videos, I'm
going to go back in time
and dig up some of
our older episodes
so I can update them with
all the Polymer 1.0 goodness.
Today, we are starting
with Polycast numero
uno, which is on core-icons.
So I'm going to
show you how to work
with the new iron-icon element.
Let's take a look.
So today, I'm going to help you
convert the previous episode,
which worked with the
core-icon element,
to the updated iron-icon that
is now part of Polymer 1.0.
Many of the elements that were
previously in the core set
have now been ported to either
the iron set or the paper set.
And the general rule of thumb
that I like to keep in my head
is if the previous element
was mostly just behavior,
then it has probably been
moved to the iron element set.
If it had a bit of UI to it,
like perhaps the core toolbar
or the core header panel,
anything that's sort of visual,
then it has been moved
to the paper element set.
So we're going to be working
with iron-icon today.
The first thing
we're going to do
is go over to the catalog at
elements.polymerproject.org
and go and click on
the Iron Elements set
to get the documentation.
And I'll just find the docs
for the iron-icon element
inside of here.
And you'll notice that if you've
watched the previous episode,
a lot of these things
are the same from before.
We've still got a
Source attribute
if you're working with sources.
If you are working
directly with an icon,
there is still the
Icon attribute.
So many of the
things are similar
from the previous video.
The one thing that I do
want to point out here
is a little bit
further down the page.
You'll see a section on styling.
And this is going
to mention styling
using custom properties.
Now, if you're not familiar
with custom properties,
we covered those in
a previous episode.
So if you go check
out this episode,
it will explain how
custom properties work.
I recommend you
go and watch that
before watching the
rest of this episode
because we're going to
use these in a little bit.
OK.
Now, to install these
in my application,
I'm going to hop over
into my terminal.
And I will run
bower install, save.
And you'll notice here that
I'm installing from Polymer
elements/iron-icons.
All of the Polymer element
sets or whatever now
live in this Polymer
elements org on GitHub.
So any time you're
bower installing,
you're doing it from
Polymer elements.
That's going to go out
and fetch the repo,
download it to my application.
So I'm ready to rock.
Now if I open my
project up in Sublime,
I've actually got the old
project from the old episode.
And we're going to go
through and update this.
So I open up my Bower
components directory.
And you'll see that
inside of here,
we've got both the iron-icon
element, as well as
the iron-icons element.
So by installing iron-icons,
I got iron-icon for free
because it depends on it.
Next, I'm going to open
my index HTML file.
And scrolling down
here, I'm going
to replace the old polyfills.
These are quite
old at this point.
So we're going to update them
to use webcomponents-lite.js.
That is the polyfill set
we use in Polymer 1.0.
And then instead of
importing core-icons,
we will import iron-icons.
And that is going to import both
the default icon set, as well
as the iron-icon element.
So I can use that default set.
Now, the next thing
I want to do is
go down here to where
it says core-icon
and replace these with
my individual iron-icons.
So I can just go and
delete all these.
We're going to
use the same icon.
We'll use that android icon.
But this time, we'll use the
iron-icon element to do it.
So iron-icon, icon
equals android, right?
Pretty straightforward.
I can go boot up a local server.
And then I'll zoom
in here, and you
can see that we've got our
Android icon displaying.
So we're all good there.
OK.
So if you go to
the Element catalog
because you want to add
some additional icons
to your application and you want
to look up what they're called,
logically, you're
going to go and look
for the iron-icons
element set docs.
And what you're going
to find is a blank page
because there is a bug
in the catalog right now.
So I know about this little
special URL, which is basically
you take a demo file from
somewhere else in the catalog,
and then you just replace
the URL with iron-icons.
And that's actually
going to load
in the docs for your
iron-icons for you.
It's a total hack.
To make your life easier, I will
give you a little annotation
here that you can click on.
So this will take you
right to the icon docs.
This is a bug that we
have open in the catalog.
We're going to get
it fixed really soon.
If you're watching
this in the future,
maybe it's already fixed.
But if you're
watching this today,
and you want to read the
docs, click that annotation.
It'll save you a little
bit of a headache there.
Now, once I hit that URL, I'm
going to see the full default
elements set.
So this is everything that I
got in my iron-icons import.
And if I scroll down, there
are actually other element sets
as well that I could
use in my application.
So here's one called AV
for audiovisual icons.
And looking around, I can
see that this AV snooze
icon down here, right about
here, looks pretty neat.
Right?
So maybe I want to use
that in my application.
So I'll hop back
into my project.
And you'll see that when I
open up the iron-icons set,
that inside of here, there's
a few different icon sets.
There are the AV icons.
So I just need to
import that element set.
So I will drop an import after
where I pulled in iron icons.
And here, I'm going
to import AV icons.
Now all of those icons will
be available to me as well.
So copy in my iron-icon and
drop in one that says av:snooze.
And anytime you're using an
icon from a set that is not
the default set, you're
going to need to prefix it
with the set name and a colon.
Now when I hop back
into my editor,
you can see I've
got my Android icon,
and I've got my AV snooze icon.
Now, the last thing that I
want to do-- as you recall,
we can style the elements
using these custom properties
for width and height.
So I'm going to hop
back into my editor
and create a theme.html file.
And inside of this file, I'm
going to create a custom style
property.
So style is custom style.
And I can treat this kind
of like a style sheet.
So I'll target the
iron-icon element.
And now I can target the custom
properties inside of this.
So I'm just going to
make all iron-icons have
a really big width and
height so that they're
visible from space, basically.
So I've set width and height.
I'm going to import
my theme file.
And now when I go back to my
browser and refresh the page,
I've got these ginormous icons.
So again, it's kind of
absurd to make them this big.
But this way, you can
globally set the size
for all of your iron-icons.
Or if you wanted to
target it by class,
you can do these
different things.
And in this case, it's
not a very huge use
of custom properties.
But I want to get you familiar
with custom properties.
I want to get you
comfortable using them
because we're going to be using
them a lot more in the future.
So that about does it.
You've now got the
latest and greatest info
on working with
icons in Polymer 1.0.
That's it for this week, folks.
Be sure to click that
little Subscribe button.
As always, thank you
so much for watching.
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]